state
the military coup many young activists
came out onto the street to protest but
the military did not care they cracked
down on the protests causing many people
to want to leave I had to leave Kaya
state in September 2021 because I was
helping injured protesters and had
become too well known to the military
a few of my colleagues had been arrested
and I began to feel unsafe
the military went to some of the people
I had helped and wanted to know my name
and where I lived
I feared for my family's safety
so I decided to leave
when we arrived in mon state they passed
a new law forcing people to report and
register any guests or visitors
we were easily identifiable as strangers
as we looked different to the local
people so we continued on to miyawadi
then like but we faced the same problem
we had no choice but to cross the border
into Thailand I wrote to the unhcr in
December 2021 and had an interview with
them a few months later
but I heard nothing more so I applied to
Australia for Refugee status but I was
rejected that affected me a lot mentally
I have a wife and child but life is so
uncertain I don't know if or when the
Thai authorities will arrest and Deport
me I've sent letters to many embassies
including the U.S Canada and Norway
all of them tell me the same thing that
I need to have a un registration number
from the unhcr otherwise they can't help
me
in Mesa on the border I was arrested by
the Thai police I tried to call the
unhcr emergency number several times but
there was no response in the end I had
to pay a bribe to stop them from
deporting me I was very lucky I worry as
my parents and family members are still
in Myanmar
so I try to keep a low profile while
continuing to support the Freedom
Fighters
it's important not to draw too much
attention from the military
I send food and medical supplies from
Thailand
I try to help all civilians in Kaya
State regardless of which group they
belong to we're all human beings inside
Myanmar the revolution is taking longer
and it's not easy to raise funds I'm a
singer and I plan to upload some of my
songs to YouTube
once I get more than a million views
YouTube will pay me and I will donate
the money to the cause
[Music]